sí pasará pocas horas
estadounidense ahora de la tarde se
reunirá con Joe biden se reuniría la
casa blanca sería una reunión bilateral
de varias horas no solamente con el con
el presidente sino también con el equipo
de seguridad nacional y también con el
gabinete después de esta reunión
ofrecería
declaraciones a los medios de
comunicación antes de dar el esperado
discurso que tendrá en el congreso en
plenaria del Congreso
a las horas de la noche donde pues
trabajará para pues aprobar este
presupuesto militar del 2023 pero lo que
se espera mañana después de esta reunión
precisamente con Joe biden es que
Estados Unidos pues haga un anuncio un
anuncio de dos mil millones de dólares
más de ayuda sobre todo en un programa
de defensa de los misiles
estos misiles pues serán enviados a
Ucrania Pero antes de eso habría un
entrenamiento a militares ucranianos que
vendrían a Estados Unidos para saber
cómo usar estos misiles de defensa para
la infraestructura ucraniana que está
siendo atacada por fuerzas ru